foreign
how do you find the right partner in my
case husband After experiencing a
childhood sexual abuse I don't know
what's normal in my head I like I see
other people in relationships and I see
like obviously see it on TV read about
in books like I don't feel like I know
what to do
[Music]
what's up this is John the Dr John
deloney show
the greatest mental health and marriage
parenting podcast ever
Christmas
for those of you who survived Christmas
hopefully we all survive Christmas it's
one of my favorite things about
recording a show that's four weeks three
to four weeks out is uh I don't know
maybe I'll get hit by a meteorite one
night and uh the show's never air
but we're talking about this I hope that
doesn't happen hey I hope you had a
great Christmas hope you got all the
stuff that you wanted hope you gave like
you gave and you gave and you gave
and I hope you don't have a huge credit
card bill to deal with now I hope you
are wise in your spending and in your
giving and here we are we're a couple
days from New Year's
my favorite favorite favorite favorite
favorite time of the year and
um I want to say personally I am so
grateful the Christmas deck of questions
for humans sold out in eight seconds the
New Year's deck sold out in 32 seconds
and now we have created for questions
for humans uh second editions for
friends and for lovers and multiple
groups
um and here's what I want you to think
about this is on my New Year's
resolution list I got wildly wildly busy
I didn't get wild I just got Lamer but I
got really busy in 2022 and I told my
wife the other day
oh my gosh I travel the country telling
people to make sure they have friends in
community and connection and I find
myself in a season of being really
lonely again and that's a hundred
percent on me I worked like crazy I
traveled like crazy I got home and I
would just collapse instead of reaching
out and I took opportunities to not be
weird and just be a gas gonna go to bed
I'm just gonna read a book or whatever
and so this year I'm being highly
intentional about getting out there and
um surrounding myself with some
community and I've got a couple new
Buddies who moved to town I got some
friends that I've made over the last
couple years since I've lived in
Nashville I'm looking forward to it I'm
excited to do it and one of those
components is going to be these
questions for humans um the second
edition those are coming by the way
we're not there yet but they're coming
um so hey let's do this real quick let's
do questions for humans friends second
edition
in the booth nobody's looking at me
let's do this
all right ask a question you're just
producing the heck out of this thing
aren't you no I'm just filling in and
doing my best I can whatever okay what
um
what obscure podcast are you obsessed
with right now
if it's obscure because I I think people
know that I love murder like Kelly
murder with my husband
that's the name of a podcast murder with
my husband murder with my husband and I
try to get my husband to listen to it
with me but he does not uh like it as
much as I do we can if we listen to it
he's like one at a time that's all he
can take
um he doesn't is it is he does he have
to ration it because of the murder
yes yes he does but he still sometimes
will listen to it with me but it's
pretty cool it's a wife who she knows
all about these cases and she's like
informing her husband of them and
telling him about them
I hope that you and your husband just
I don't know what do I say to that like
do murder well together or oh I hope
murders we're just educated
ah jeez okay
um
I still don't listen to a lot of
podcasts I would say the most obscure
when I listen to It's not obscurest is
the drive with Dr Peter attia I think
he's one of the most brilliant men on
the planet hopefully we can have him on
the show here in the next few months
he's got a new book coming out that I'm
super excited about
um that's probably the most I don't know
I haven't listened to a lot of podcasts
uh okay last one
be honest and you can't lie Jenna and
let's be honest that's one of the
challenges you struggle with is you
don't tell the truth a lot how often do
you change your bed sheets
once a week live no I do once a week and
I watch them on Sundays as my I change
out my sheets
really Sarah does too yes
my wife does too what your wife does
yeah yeah she yes
honestly if it was up to me to change my
bed sheets
it would probably be like an annual plan
a semi-annual plan
yeah every day no not every time I mean
every week yes what happens do you not
shower before you go to bed oh my gosh I
do shower but think about like all when
you're sleeping the dead skin cells like
throughout the week that no oh gosh once
a year more than once a year once a week
seems like oh like not great our
ancestors slept in leaves in piles and
then we've evolved and we've learned
we've evolved oh man I jeez we have
overly hygienic people in the booth hey
for those of you who
questions for humans everybody go pick
them up go to John deloney.com there's
uh several decks out there go grab them
just hours of fun you get to find out
all about each other they're all nodding
in there Joe how often do you wash your
sheets every two weeks that's a little
more I can stomach that a little bit
more
once a week that's so wasteful
no it's not it's not no all right not at
all all right
he's like
Andrew's like y'all wash your sheets
what is that that's so strange
um all right hey if you want to be on
this show give me a buzz one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one talk about mental health we talk
about what's going on in your life talk
about healing from abuse and Trauma
um what's going on with your kids going
through kids schools whatever you
whatever you got going on give me a buzz
uh
1-844-693-3291 and we'll get you on the
show all right let's go to Jose and
there's no way this is the name of his
town in Niceville Florida I love it Jose
Niceville is that for real
yes sir dude I thought you were just
giving us a fake name Niceville
no not at all is it right next to like
never mind never mind that's gonna take
it I was gonna take us off the rails uh
hey so what's up man
uh first off thank you for thank you for
your call and thank you for everything
you do on your show it it has helped me
and my family out a lot thank you well
I'm really grateful man thank you so
what's up what are you what are you
working through
so my question is how do I handle
anxiety when it comes to flying so
it for whatever reason recently my I get
super anxious I get nervous I get sweaty
I get all these different emotions when
I start flying and um I don't know
has there been any uh changes in your
life like new kids
um y'all recently buy a house you got
other stuff going on job like jobs kind
of wonky what's going on so so I've been
thinking about this a lot okay so
recently in the last two years
my life has been amazing with my wife
with my kids with my job it's like
everything is flowing in place
and I'm scared on losing it and
I don't
my wife and I had been married uh 14
years and
it hasn't been this good
almost ever
and so so
man I'm smiling
oh dude Jose I feel like I'm talking to
a cooler version of myself
um I hate flying and I fly for a living
and I hate it and
ah man I've I've been in a season of
blessing the last couple years it's not
gonna last forever and I have begun to
slowly hold on to it Tighter and Tighter
to the point that I'm gonna start
constricting it I can already tell start
choking it to death right yeah and when
I start grabbing for control all that
phobia is of the fear of flying
let's be super clear your mortal body is
in a tube a metal tube flying five or
six hundred miles an hour 30 000 feet
above the air
right so that's insane you we I think we
all should be a little bit anxious about
that because that's nuts
um our brains don't have an evolutionary
um
switch for flying in a metal tube 30 000
feet above the air
um and so we should be a little bit
anxious about that but when you're have
started to lock in on not losing things
there's just a natural inclination to
begin to hold on to things Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and then your body
starts scanning the environment for
things it cannot control and it tries to
get your attention
okay and that's all anxiety is is just
an alarm system and there are fewer
things more out of control than looking
at two dudes that you don't even get to
see they just you hear their voice and
you just trust hope you guys don't kill
us
uh and I would like the snack please and
um seltzer water right that's just it's
it's insanity
and so uh here here's a here's what I'm
gonna just tell you what I do okay okay
the first thing is when my body starts
getting anxious I about flying and it's
kind of a ramp up for me I start packing
I put off packing until the very last
second and then I create a whirling
dervish of chaos and I start throwing
crap in I always forget something and
then I get mad I forgot it
um and then I race to the airport
driving too fast because I've now
created a situation where I'm gonna be
late and I'm already amped up
and then I start getting nervous and all
the things I literally will consciously
take a deep breath and exhale and drop
my shoulders down
and I will force a giant smile onto my
face
and I will say to myself sometimes out
loud like like a person who is no longer
well or sane
I know you're just trying to take care
of me because I'm getting ready to go
flying at 30 000 feet in the air
I'm good I'm going on this flight
and I head in that way and I literally
will feel that and I'll let it run
through me and generally speaking by the
time I make it all the way to the gate
and I sit down in kind of a
I'm usually pretty good A couple other
things that help me is gum I chew I'll
go through a whole pack of sugar-free
gum not a pack of like six but like a
box of gum okay I also have headphones
and I've downloaded you can get on the
podcast and download like I don't know
it sounds like a yoga music or like
massage music or something um binaural
beats is something I love and I will
just listen to those and I just I
basically here's what I'm accepting
that I have put my hands my life in the
hands of two men or women that I'll
probably never make eye contact with and
that I'm probably not gonna die and if I
do there's nothing I can do about it
because I've already decided I'm Gonna
Fly
you see what I'm saying at that point
it's too late it's too late the ship has
sailed like yeah it's like trying I
don't want to fight I don't want to
fight well you're a boxer and they just
ding the Bell so you're in a fight now
now the only question is how badly are
you gonna get beat up or you can
actually try to fight back so when it
comes to this I feel it I smile about it
I don't go to war with my body most of
the angst with anxiety is fighting the
anxiety itself or getting anxious about
getting anxious have you gotten there
yet
yeah so for me it happens like a day
before yeah so the day before like I'll
pack I'll get ready then like I'll take
the kids out we'll go to the beach we'll
go get dinner we'll go do something and
uh one of the things in my mind is like
man what if this is the last time I see
my kids or the last time I see my wife
and that whole first day is run into my
mind until I get to the airport then
when I get to the airport it's like all
right don't die but like you're saying I
have no control yeah so I actually think
the question what if this is the last
day I could see my kids there's a
question we should all ask way way way
more often
because the majority of us run through
our lives as though our current
situation is never going to end both
good and bad
those of us in a season of blessing just
assume we're always going to make this
much money in the life our lights are
always going to be on there's always
going to be this and the car is always
going to start and the tires are never
going to be flat and then we all have a
rude awakening coming for us and those
that think I'm always going to be
depressed I'm always going to be anxious
I'm always going to be just a trauma
Survivor they'd have a hard time seeing
this that the sun comes up too and so I
would tell you that don't run from that
actually sit for a minute and I would
actually do it more often than just that
one day what if it's the last day I see
my kids one of the things that I did
regularly I need to get back into it in
2023 is I would write my kids a quick
letter
I just want you to know that I love you
I just want you to know that I'm so
proud I'm so grateful that I get to be
your dad and my subversive motive for
that was what if this is the last time I
get to see him
I want that that when their dad dies in
a plane crash which by the way
statistically speaking is never gonna
happen it's never gonna happen you and I
statistically speaking of way more
likelihood they were going to die in our
cars frantically driving to the airport
that we are in a car and a plane ride
crash but I wanted them to have that
letter and for some reason writing that
letter to them before I left town was
good leaving a letter on my wife's
pillow
um if she was gone already or um right
by where the coffee maker is in the
morning when I knew she was going to go
first thing in the morning man that gave
me peace because I get to say the last
the last words does that make sense
no it does and it makes a lot of sense I
I don't have any problem with you
thinking what if this is the last moment
I think this is I think that helps us
make our time a little more precious
that's an old stoic philosophy
um Memento Mori like remember we're
gonna die
when that it's when that becomes
paralyzing and I can't get on a plane
and then I can't leave the house and I
can't you know I mean that's when it
gets too far that's when our bodies spin
out on us that's why I think showing
actually get in the car going to the
airport and smiling dropping your
shoulders and saying
huh
this is it
I'm not gonna die and if I do nothing I
can do about it because I'm getting on
this plane and by the way real quick
Jose I want to back out for just one
second
um
things are really good and you've worked
really good to create a non-anxious life
and you're in a season of blessing
and so things like an emergency fund
for if you lose your job or something
breaks on the house
let me say it this way if worrying or
anxiousness is your drug
seasons of Peace will feel like hell
they will feel
um like you're not prepared you're not
ready
it's that dream that you wake up and
you're supposed to be giving a
presentation at school and you haven't
studied or you're the guitarist of a
band and you're suddenly on stage you
know how to play the song
and that that dream comes to life for
those of us who have lived lives of
worry and anxiousness for whatever
reason seasons of Peace feel very
foreboding
um I think it's brene brown that says we
start rehearsing tragedy
we start practicing for when it all goes
down
and man I just decided to quit living
like that I have prepared my life as
much as possible for if and when things
can happen I don't have a plan for if
the monetary system collapses and we're
trading coffee and bullets for food I
don't have a plan for that
um my plan is to go find a prepper and
do never mind so I
I've planned appropriately and now I've
been in a season the last four or five
years of practicing being at peace it's
practicing
practicing living non-anxiously and it's
been incredible
because my body's adjusted
and it can Gear Up what it needs to but
most of the time it lives in a state of
so good so Jose I want you to I want to
challenge you brother
intentionally open your hands
to your incredible marriage to your
incredible relationship with your kids
to your good situation at home and at
work
hold those things Loosely because
they're going to cut they're not they're
not gonna come and go your family's not
gonna come and go but
there's gonna be seasons of good times
and seasons of tough times and if you
hang on to the good times so hard you'll
end up suffocating them while they're
still good times
hold on to them Loosely build yourself a
non-anxious life
and then learn practice
on dealing with whatever comes
because it's gonna come anyway right I
might as well not go to war premium
Charlie I might as well enjoy the peace
when there's peace and enjoy the good
times when they're good and be prepared
for when times get tough
you're worrying and being anxious about
them never helped with any of those
things I'm grateful grateful for you
brother and congratulations on building
a non-anxious life we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right all right let's go to uh
Bloomington
where the flower is Bloom and just talk
to Melanie what's up Melanie how are we
doing
hi Dr John how are you
I'm good how are you I literally
couldn't be better doing pretty good
good that's not true find some gummy
candies so what's up what's up
oh I'm calling because
I
struggle with seeing my dad's marriage
as something good
and I want to find a way to have peace
with being second to my step family
hmm
tell me more about that
so my parents divorced when I was 11
years old okay because my dad had an
affair
and he married his mistress as soon as
the divorce was Final okay
um I'm 36 years old right now
and I'm still
I still see that every time
I'm with them
it just
so
um for 27 years and I'm going to give
you
27 years wouldn't be fair because you
were 11.
um so you're 36 so let's just say 25.
for 11 years
you've deliberately chosen misery
either yeah you've chosen misery you've
chosen to hang out with him in a
violation of your own boundaries
wondering the whole time this 11 year
old little girl daddy why are you
picking her over us why are you picking
her over us
and you've continued that conversation
or misery you willfully want to go you
want him to continue to be your dad you
want him to continue being your life and
you have to be with
also with a woman who you have pegged as
the person who helped ruin your life
like why have you why have you chosen
this Loop for 11 years
um
I saw how it affected my mom
and
she has passed away
um she passed away in 2016. oh man
um and she was just a wonderful person
um
foreign
and it's just just like what you just
said it's hard to see
that he chose
another family
um over us
and I've done okay with it for a long
while like I have not dwelled on it this
entire time
like it was actually doing okay
um
what has started up is the last year
I've been spending more time with them
like trying because
you know I love my dad I want him in my
life and I want to be in his life I mean
because he's not a bad person
here's the big question does he want you
in his life
I believe he does okay
do you want him in your life because you
actually love him and care about him and
and you've forgiven him and you want to
have a new kind of you want to build a
new relationship with him or do you want
him because your mom has passed away and
he's all you got left or do you want him
because you are still desperately
hanging on to a fantasy that at some
point this all works out
I feel like it's a combination of all of
that all of it yeah
I want to clear all of the decks okay
let's just clear everything let's just
take our arm and swipe it across the
table now we've got a clean table
okay instead of wading through all the
junk on this one
let's go to the very very end
you're 36 fast forward to your 40th
birthday
what do you want that to look like
when it comes to you and your dad
paint me a very very Vivid picture
um
I would like us to be closer nope that's
two that's two or more like paint me who
do you want at the kitchen who you
wanted at the dining room table do you
want your dad to swoop you up and take
you somewhere like what do you want your
40th birthday to look like
I would love but if he called me up and
said hey I would like to spend time with
you on your birthday
this is your 40th
and
I love you and
I want to spend time with you today
just us and
just
spend time together okay I'm doing what
it doesn't even have to be anything big
we can go to dinner and talk we can
be at his house
and as long as she's not there right
well it's not like I I don't hate the
woman
it had that blood I don't hate the woman
I mean kinda you do but
um so I went okay I want to go one layer
deeper tell me you're sitting at dinner
with him
how do you feel
like right now where you are put your
hand on your chest how do you feel
you're sitting at a table with your dad
no no no that's what I'm asking fast
forward fast forward to your 40th
birthday
oh okay the waiter he you just saw it
caught your dad sneaking around telling
the waiter that it's her birthday and
they're gonna do some obnoxious
sing-along thing and he sits back down
and he smiles at you and he says
man so glad to be doing this with you
how do you feel in that moment
I would feel very happy well I that's
happiest happy cocaine and cotton candy
that's not real how do you feel
loved
uh
and you exhaled after you said love
you feel loved finally
yes okay
that's that 11 year old girl saying why
did you pick her over me
yes
okay
and my promise to you is if all of this
played out just from right now just in
not just the current state of your
relationship and you ended up having
that moment it would be mixed with
um
what you just like this piece this I
feel loved my dad showed up for my 40th
birthday and what you can't feel now is
my guess would be it would also be
filled with rage
like you wasted 29 or 30 years ago like
that right and so it'd be this weird
cocktail that feels like it would feel
good right now so let me ask you a hard
question
would you be able to
invite your dad out
and have written him a letter and read
him the letter
part of that letter would say
inside of me is an 11 year old little
girl still wondering why you chose that
family over me
why you chose that family over me and
Mom and if you've got other siblings you
can name them
and then the other part of that letter
is
Daddy I have a dream that for my 40th
birthday you'll just invite me out and
we'll get to spend the day together like
we never got to do
I want to get to know you well enough so
that when that happens I'm really
excited about it
and here's here's why I'm suggesting you
do something like this
or let me ask you like you the idea that
you would do that how do you feel about
that
I I feel okay with that because I've
been holding it in for this whole time
we've never had that conversation so I
do want to so I want to validate you
this should be the conversation your dad
has with you because he's your dad
yes and it's been 29 years and hasn't
happened yet so you as an adult are
faced with a choice
am I gonna walk away
um or am I gonna keep wishing
and I expect him to read my mind
or even worse am I going to live in the
ambiguity
and what you're doing is a gift to
yourself you're just calling it
you've been playing poker long enough
and he made me Bluff in I don't
dad do you love me
and when you ask it when you sit down
and read him this letter he may stop
halfway through and say whoa whoa I'm
out of here
I left this when you were 11.
and I'm not here for it anymore I mean
I'm not here for it now he could walk
out and what you would get is
devastating grief and you'd get some
clarity
you could you'd be able to stop chasing
that that that that dragon
the other side of it is
you could
have 30 more years of relationship with
him
but you would have to decide
to forgive him
and stop carrying that baggage
yes
yeah
it feels like that baggage is protecting
you and it's not
it's weighing you down
or to say it another way
your hatred for him for what he did to
your mom combined with your love for him
as an 11 year old little girl still
chasing for chasing him chasing him
chasing his Blessing chasing his
Blessing chasing his Blessing
that combination there that's just you
drinking poison
and unfortunately for him he can't read
your mind
and you're expecting him to be a mind
reader just call me just call me and he
should he should call his daughter and
yeah he just has it
yeah
and he probably can't give you a good
reason if you sat down and said why
didn't you call it he probably couldn't
tell you other than maybe he said I was
I knew you'd be so disappointed I didn't
want to bother you
because he might think he's a burden who
knows I don't want to get inside his
head I don't know why he's doing he's
doing but the end of the day
what comes next is on you
he has proven he's not going to do that
and if you told me dude I'm out of his
life I'm making peace with this I'm
going to write the letter I'm not going
to send it I'm going to be done
I'm going to let him know how much he
hurt me I'm going to let him know all
the great things that have happened
since he walked out on me
and I am going to let him know of the
things that I'm doing in my life and the
things that are to the are to come
he didn't get to be a part of that
basically you'd be grieving him just
like you grieved your mom
he's gone yeah
or you can choose to seek reconciliation
knowing that that's going to leave you
open to be heard again
foreign
yes but also leave you very open for
some clarity
so what do you think what are you gonna
do
I think I would like to
write the letter and
read it to him I do want to give
that a chance okay y'all live in the
same town
um
mostly uh he was living out of state but
he's recently
moved back
he comes back more than he used to
gotcha
so that's how I've been able to spend
more time with him
gotcha
I
I can't tell you what to do in this
situation yeah
I would also recommend that you take his
relationship with your mom
off of your plate
because there will be Dynamics to that
relationship that you will never fully
understand because you weren't in it it
wasn't your relationship all you got to
do is see it from
um from one side and experience it as a
child
so moving forward things are about his
relationship with you
and the ways he's hurt you the way he's
potentially blessed you both of those
things are true
um
and what you two decide
what comes next is going to look like
and I would even include that language
in your letter
none of us can change what happened in
the past the only thing we can change is
what happens next
and ask him are you in
and then be prepared this is the hard to
be prepared to tell him what in means
this means you take me to breakfast once
a week dad or once a month dad
this means we go to movies because you
should have taken me to movies when we
were kids and you never took me so now
you're playing catch-up do you have kids
of your own
no I don't okay are you married
no
that was an awesome laugh
um
if that time comes you invite him into
that too right I'll have to say is this
what do you want that to look like but
I can tell you if it was me I would
probably err on I I would do what you're
doing
um Life's too short for me to carry
somebody else's bricks not gonna do it
um Life's too short for me to drink
poison hoping that somebody else dies
Life's too short for me expecting people
in my life to be mind readers I've just
started being very clear and sometimes
that clearness comes across as like that
guy's a jerk or that guy's demanding
that's fine but everybody's on the same
page and that is an infinitely healthier
place to be
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your pass change your future
I want you to read that as you are
writing this letter
read them do those things together read
the book and write that letter together
because the book's going to give you
some insight into your own stories that
you've picked up along the way and that
you've been telling yourself for a long
time about the role you played and your
dad leaving which is nonsense
and then it's going to give you some
tools on that one terrifying scary
question
who what do we do next
what do we do next thanks for sharing us
uh sharing your life with us Melanie
appreciate it let us know how that
conversation goes give us a call back
because I want to know uh
hopefully he grabs Your Hands Across
that table and says hey honey I am all
in we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here I know I know
it's the holidays you're super busy and
between all the decorating Christmas
trees and Christmas parties and your
friends drinking too much eggnog family
visits so many family visits it's so
easy to skimp on sleep don't fall into
that trap my friends you've got to take
care of yourself and your mental health
during the holidays and that means
prioritizing sleep sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your mental
health any time of year but especially
right now and for me getting deep
restorative sleep starts with a good
mattress and that's why my family sleeps
on dream Cloud mattresses and right now
dream cloud is running an unbelievable
offer exclusively for my listeners get
25 off any mattress 599 dollars in
accessories that's pillows a mattress
protector and luxury sheets plus an
additional 50 cash discount when you use
promo code deloni so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com
or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo
code deloni to get your new mattress
today
all right we are back uh let's go to my
hometown h-tone and talk to Ellie what's
up Ellie
hey how are you I'm all right how about
you
pretty good very cool so what's going on
there in Houston Texas
okay so my question is
how do you find the right partner in my
case husband After experiencing
childhood sexual abuse
foreign
I'm only smiling you just like walked
into my living room and you sound so
kind and you're like here's a grenade
and I've pulled the pin and you'll have
a great day so tell me tell me more
that's a huge sentence there tell me
more about that
um
used between the ages of seven and
eleven by
um a really close family friend
okay can I stop can I stop right there
and say I'm sorry
thank you
but do you you know that shouldn't have
happened right
yes okay all right good
oh man okay so seven to eleven
um did your parents know
they did not they didn't find out until
I was
um
17. okay
how'd they find out
um
my mom actually read something I had
written like the only time I had ever
written anything down because I felt
like I couldn't take it anymore
and um she had to go hunting for it too
so I guess I don't know but she she
found it she read it and she
lost it
so they had they had literally no idea
EE okay
where's this guy now
he died okay how did he pass away
a heart attack
okay
so how old are you now
I'm 28 28.
how are your teenage years
um
I mean I did well in school I hated
school so I tried to get done with it as
fast as I could and
[Music]
um
moved out as soon as I could
and it wasn't that eventful I mean I was
pretty
pretty miserable I would say through my
teenage years but
um no one really asked anything
we were just kind of like oh she's just
a
typical teenager
and then you got the grade unit to keep
people off your back and you were just
quiet enough and didn't set anything on
fire and everybody just kind of let you
let you do your thing
yeah and I have a sibling who's
a hot mess so
I think the focus is kind of always on
them instead
she had you had a chance to hide
yep okay
so you're 28 tell me how what dating has
been like for you
I feel like that's the understatement of
the day not great absolutely
am I not great I mean absolutely
terrible okay
um I mean I've had one
serious relationship
and definitely was not a healthy
relationship
what does that mean
um I I didn't really really actually
trust him okay and
makes me a little nervous
I'm just afraid that I'm never gonna be
able to trust anyone
okay
when you say it wasn't a good
relationship and you didn't trust him
something happened or something happened
regularly what was it
he didn't really listen to me I guess
like he or he listened to me but he
didn't hear me
okay
when I would kind of say like these are
my boundaries he didn't really he didn't
necessarily always respect them
and I just have like the most
skewed you I like I don't know I don't
know what's normal
in my head I like ice i see keep other
people in relationships and I see like
obviously see it on TV read about in
books like all that kind of stuff but I
don't like I don't feel like I know what
to do
so tell me if I'm off here okay there's
this thing
um
by gowitz and maidan and I think it's oh
fear and La Vie uh the two researchers
and they have this idea called the
sexual self-concept
and it's a conglomeration of things but
it's this idea of of the things you
think about yourself combined with the
experiences you've had
um that create this
way you experience yourself when it
comes to sexuality and
when kids are sexually abused
their sexual self-concept
and for a lack of better terms it just
it it goes to Ash it burns to the ground
it explodes right and so you find
yourself
um
I am good for the sexual pleasure of
other other people
so you might date somebody and say hey I
don't want anything physical
and then you find yourself being
sexually active with somebody because
there's a your sexual self-concept is my
job is to fulfill other people's needs
or
my sexual self-concept is I'm broken
because somebody broke me when I was a
child and nobody's ever gonna fully want
me
because I'm not I I am is there
something wrong with me
and so you hold back
and don't tell the full truth the whole
truth or nothing but the truth and you
can't because it's a preservation method
and because you can't tell the whole
truth you assume and your body
experiences other people aren't telling
you the truth
or worse
maybe because of these secrets that you
hold these things that happen to you
by somebody who you trusted and more
importantly your family trusted and even
when you no longer trusted Mom and Dad
continue to trust which is
unmooring it pulls a child into two
different human beings
suddenly you feel like if I love
somebody I'm going to be a burden to
them they're going to be worse off
because they're with me
then they would be otherwise are any of
those three hitting home
uh yes
yes
definitely
what is what happens to your body when
you date somebody and I don't mean in a
sexual way I mean like in an anxious
anxiety response kind of way
um
I'm just a nervous wreck the entire time
okay
I mean I
and you know you think like well I think
okay if I keep doing this if I keep
putting myself in this situation
eventually it'll get easier right no
it is not who told you that it would
eventually get easier
I don't know
so myself I guess let me let me see this
um and I can be guilty of this too
the only way through anxiety is
I mean the only way to heal from anxiety
is directly through the middle of it
okay
when it comes to Childhood sexual abuse
and adult intimacy
you can't power your way through it
it's got to go in steps someone's got to
walk with you
okay because it overwhelms the system
if you just try to just like all right
my body's doing this thing all right I'm
just gonna go date I'm just gonna do it
I'm gonna stand here and smile your body
goes oh hey El you're clearly not
getting our message so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna shut the whole
thing down right here in the movie
theater you want to watch because here
it goes see it right see what I'm saying
yes or you're at dinner and you find
yourself crying for no reason or
laughing hysterically or he just does
like one of those moves where he just
reaches to grab the the napkin but he
accidentally brushes your finger just to
see what your reaction is because maybe
he can hold hands and your whole body
goes into a rage right whatever the your
body's trying to get your attention
have you ever gone to talk to somebody
do you ever spend some seasoned uh some
Seasons doing some
trauma counseling
um
yes
you don't it wasn't effective
um
I I mean I
have a lot of ways but um
not necessarily in this
particular okay when's the last time you
went saw counselor
last year
tell me about that experience
uh I didn't even really bring up
dating per se like I didn't I feel like
there were other things that I was
struggling with like what
um
well I mean I initially went back
because I was struggling with
um my my sibling has mental health
issues and
um
so I kind of went back because I was
trying to deal with that trying to
figure out how to
navigate that relationship with my
parents like maintain a relationship
with my parents but
distance myself
gotcha from your unsafe sibling so
here's what I want you to do I want you
to
go find a good trauma therapist and let
them know I was sexually abused from a
family friend
for four or five years during some of
the most important developmental time in
my life right under my mom and dad's
nose
and I'm just putting this into The Ether
it might not be true but you grew up in
a pretty chaotic home environment huh
Fair
uh yeah sometimes yeah
so I want you to be very open about the
environment you grew up in
and
just listening to you talk you haven't
made peace with but you are able to say
I was abused as a kid
you haven't done a lot of talking about
what you experienced in your own home
have you
no okay you've got to talk about that
and the purpose for talking through
these things is not to relive them or
re-traumatize ourselves or have to go
re-experience all this stuff the purpose
is because I want to have grown-up
relationships myself
and my parents painted me a horrible
picture of what that looks like
a man that my family trusted
destroyed me
for his own pleasure
and I have tried to White Knuckle my way
through this and I I need different
tools
and so we're not just going to sit there
and spin like a record player but we're
gonna actually heal towards you making
true adult connections because that's
going to be the important part of your
healing moving forward
is true connection with other human
beings
and I wish there was another way to do
this there's just simply not
are you willing to do that
yeah yes
um I'll tell you a couple other things I
would love for you to do I would love
for you to get
um some sort of
movement practice and I know they have a
million different things there in
Houston whether it's a yoga practice or
a jiu jitsu class or some sort of the
body stores trauma in really bananas
ways and if you've ever been to a yoga
class for a long period of time or Jiu
Jitsu class for a long period of time
there sometimes somebody will just start
sobbing
and there's something about movement and
healing and movement and Trauma healing
that works together I don't fully
understand at all
um I just have seen it I've experienced
it
um something else you got to get a group
of women that you trust that you can be
100 open with all of it do you have that
okay
so you've got an anxious body that in
living in an anxious environment with no
other peop no other tribe members an
unsafe family
a haunting presence that when we feel
love or sexual intimacy that means
that's that's our body goes to war goes
to fight or flight
you don't have intimate connections as
an adult you don't got friends as adult
you see how your body's going to be
anxious regardless of what's what your
past is just because of the the
ecosystem it's had to create to survive
and what we have to do is teach it how
to survive in another ecosystem and
you're going to have to get some help to
do that one final thing is
I'd love to see you begin to create a
new identity
here's what I mean by that
one where you are worth being in a
relationship with and you write that
down every day
one where every day you get up and you
write I'm worth being loved
one where you get up every day I am
worth
not being anxious all the time I'm worth
a non-anxious life I'm worth
my needs being met and that means you
have to sit down with a counselor and
figure out what the heck your needs even
are
yeah you don't even know what that means
you're gonna have to ask yourself this
one terrifying question what do I
actually want that's and that's
paralyzing for people you know what I
mean you're gonna have to figure out how
to ask you're gonna have to learn I'm a
person who communicates my needs very
very clearly
mom if brother's gonna be at your house
for the holidays I am choosing to not be
there period
I am not interested in a sexual
relationship with you right now but I
will get coffee with you cool
see what I'm saying yeah see it sounds
like Madness to you
because it just seems like such a
strange thing to say I know
it's called Boundaries they're very
strange to most of us
but especially if they're especially
strange
speaking your needs out loud clearly are
especially strange to kids who are resp
to adults who has children were
responsible for their parents emotional
regulation
foreign
for kids who grew up with a sibling with
mental illness
that may disregulated the household and
didn't have parents who leaned into that
it's especially weird
for kids who were sexually abused and
you've got all three
not to mention the things that you blame
yourself for having tried to tightrope
through relationships since then Fair
yes
because you've done things quote unquote
done things I hate that language but
you've done some things that you wish
you had know if you wish you'd spoken up
you feel like someone's taking advantage
of you you may have been sexually
assaulted again
um under the guise of well I just didn't
am I am I onto something
yeah yes you're worth more than that and
I can't be the only one who believes
that
do you believe that
yes yes
will you start
yeah
you just cut out on me
yes yes
you promise say I want you to say I'm
worth being loved
oh man
oh that's so strange
um
I'm worth being lost
yeah that felt weird to say
it again
um I'm worth being loved
I'm worth having needs
come on
I'm worth having needs
I'm worth more than the sexual
gratification of other people
I want to for some reasons like
that was tough that's tough for me to
say
so when you go see your counselor that's
where you start okay
but I need you to hear me say that it's
true
yeah you were not put on this planet
to meet somebody else's sexual needs
you're put on this planet to be a light
and a gift
and service to other people
and my gut tells me is that making the
phone call to a counselor because you've
been through some counselors before
you've got a whole bunch of shame that
you're carrying around a whole bunch of
guilt that you're carrying around which
are Hallmarks of your childhood
Hallmarks of your early adult years
making that phone call is going to be
hard
but in two years you and I are going to
look up
and you're going to be meeting with a
small group of women who have been
through the same thing
and you will begin to make meaning of
the madness and the insanity and the
evil that you've endured
and you're going to be able to forgive
this 11 year old who you have blamed for
years
or you're going to be able to forgive
this 11 year old who's been fighting on
your behalf for so long
tell me you're not are you just
exhausted
very
here's what I want you to
I want you to let that little girl
finally rest
and she hasn't been able to rest ever
my heart's broken for you Ellie
you just have to trust me that you're
worth being loved and you're worth being
well
you're worth having needs and you're
worth speaking clear boundaries
and you're worth more than the sexual
gratification of other people
you're worth finding who you want to
serve and who you want to love
and serving them and loving them in ways
that
fill you up
you're worth healing
and it's going to be hard
and I want you to know when it gets hard
and when it gets exhausting and when it
gets scary
that you've got millions of us
who are following you now we're a part
of your story you invited us in and I'm
grateful that you did that
you got millions of us walking beside
you
holding your arms up in the desert when
things get heavy when things get hard
[Music]
and I will be counting down the days
till you make that call hopefully do it
today and I will look forward to the
next couple years as hopefully you'll
reach back out let me know how you're
doing
um because you're about to become a
light brighter than anything you've ever
seen you're going to be like staring
into the sun
all that's going to start with that one
phone call to a trauma therapist and you
said I'm ready
thanks for your trust thanks for um
loving Ellie like we all do
we'll be right back
seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um it has a heavy show for the day after
Christmas
but here's what I want to say
there's a whole whole bunch of you
who went to holidays over Thanksgiving
holidays for Christmas
um
and you're having this realization I
can't make the adults in my life change
I can't
I can't make people get up when they get
knocked down I can't make people go to
counseling I can't make people stop
spending their money like I can't keep
people from watching the news 24 7 365 I
can't make people eat differently I
can't change other adults
so I want you to hear me say I get how
hard that is and that often comes with a
season of grief when you're watching
people you love just make choices that
you know are hurting them you feel it
hurting them and the holidays are just
that season
we get to see it up close
but I also want you to know that there
is one person you can change and that's
you
and so whatever 2023 is going to look
like whether we're going to have a
recession or not have a recession or
whatever politicians are good I don't
care
whatever Kanye is gonna say whatever I
don't know whatever I don't care
I can just change my thoughts and my
actions that's it
and so whether you have hard stuff to
begin to heal from like childhood sexual
abuse an academic childhood home and
choices you made
others whatever you're going through or
whether you're
just finding yourself in a season of
absolute blessing things are so good and
there's a creeping voice that's making
its way through the back of your brain
saying hey this all goes away this all
goes away don't you forget this all goes
away and you start practicing for when
it does all go away
you can control you
and all you can change is your thoughts
and your behaviors please trust me
you are worth it
those that you love are worth it your
kids are worth it your spouse your
romantic partner it's worth it worth it
worth it worth it every time
I hope you'll join me in this upcoming
new year as we
hear where we gotta heal and make new
habits and new identities and we head
off into the unknown and make them all
come true
um today's song of the day as we wrap it
up
in honor of our first caller Jose
from the Great and Mighty Foo Fighters
songs go Learning to Fly fantastic
General way to go it goes like this run
and tell all of the Angels this could
take all night think I need a devil to
help me get things right hook me up a
new Revolution because this one is a lie
we sat around laughing and watched the
last one die
and I'm looking at the sky to save me
looking for a sign of life looking for
something to help me burn out bright I'm
looking for a complication
looking cause I'm tired of lying make my
way back home when I learn to fly high
hey that's what we're doing we're
teaching each other how to fly we'll see
you soon